hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast complete workflow
solution from gene to protein combined
highly advanced expression systems with
expression optimized genes presented by
dr. Stefan bass manager of manufacturing
at Thermo Fisher Scientific ICT Valdez I
will be your moderator for this
educational webcast
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
get Co part of thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during this
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located at the lower left of your
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen I'll answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of our
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing this presentation in a
slide window to enlarge the slide window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having problems please join
me now in welcoming dr. Stephan Foss I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir well hello thank you
Susie for this introduction so yeah
welcome everybody on the computer here
from Regensburg in Germany so once again
my name is Stephan fat I am a manager
manufacturing in the Biosciences
division of same official scientific and
I am heading the protein service group
here at the genocide in Regensburg so
I'm really happy to be part of this
quite interesting web-based conference
format and I'm happy to add and yeah an
simple aspect to the agenda of this
conference and
yeah so I would like to start my talk
with a quick look at the agenda
basically show you what will be covered
during this talk I will in I will start
out with a very brief and short
introductions to gene synthesis I will
introduce you to our multi parameter
gene optimize search optimization
approach and basically show you data how
this optimization approach actually
benefits protein expression I will also
show you some data to demonstrate which
molecular mechanisms of protein
synthesis are affected by this
optimization approach before I will end
this first part of the talk talking or
introducing to another quite nice
application for optimized genes during
the second part of my talk I will
introduce you to those highly advanced
protein expression systems which are
offered through Thermo Fisher Scientific
and introduce you to our Chintu protein
service and by doing this I hopefully I
can demonstrate you how your research
can benefit from combining highly
advanced expression systems with
expression optimized genes and how we
can help you doing this by offering a
complete workflow solution from gene to
protein so anyone who has never used a
synthetic gene before those are of
course double-stranded DNA constructs
which are synthesized de novo completely
from scratch and based only on a digital
DNA or amino acid sequence and of course
they are made exclusively to according
to a scientist specification those genes
can be made more than 10 KB in length
and of course no genes leaves our house
when it's not 100% sequence verified so
you really can say when we are producing
a synthetic gene we are writing DNA and
here at chena Thermo Fisher Scientific
we are considered as the excellent
Center for writing nucleic acids for
writing DNA and the opportunities which
are offered through gene synthesis they
certainly to explain the increasing
demand and the exponentially growth in
these fears over the last couple of
years since it is simply a very
cost-effective time and resource aving
method method in order to obtain a
desired en a construct and as I will
show you it presumably will provide you
a better expression performance than any
white action so yeah just remember
yourself or imagine yourself being in
the lab you want to express a protein so
you always relied on the availability of
certain cDNA templates which often are
not available as all contain errors
simply a time-consuming process even to
get the template in your own hands and
then you had to go all the classical
step from PCR amplification to
sequencing and in the end you probably
end up with a natural gene in your
expression plasmid which has a
questionable performance by ordering
your synthetic genes routine art you
will save a lot of time time you can
spend on your actual research in the lab
and again I will show you a presumably
will provide you a better protein
expression performance
so yeah key application for synthetic
gene certainly are many fold from basic
research to selling optimization
synthetic genes are used in protein
engineering gene therapy track and
target validation but during today's
talk I strongly want to focus on protein
and here especially on antibody
optimization and production and yeah the
service portfolio we are offering here
at chena thermal sem official scientific
certainly covers the whole workflow from
project design to gene synthesis to the
highly expressed and purified protein or
if requested of course only part of it
since of course in addition to classical
gene synthesis we can also deliver gene
variants of your target up to very
complex gene libraries but again this
talk will focus on mammalian protein
expression
project so okay if your interest now is
protein production why should you go
with an optimized team and one reason
for sure and this has been known for
many many years is that of course codon
usage is affecting gene or protein
expression so you have a genetic code
which is universal you are 61 codons
coding for only 20 amino acids and out
of those 20 amino acids 18 used
synonymous codons and those alternative
codons are actually used with an unequal
frequency so just as an example if you
take a look at this code on cgt which is
calling for an arginine this actually
would be the most frequently used codon
for an arginine in an e coli expression
house however in a human cell this
actually would be the most rarely used
codon for notch e mean by contrast for
example a ga would be the most
frequently used codon for an attorney in
a human expression cell while in an e
coli cell those would be actually the
least frequently used codon and those
codon usage patterns they really differ
in each and every organism and so
apparently one factor codon usage plays
a critical role during gene expression
since the codon usage of your transgene
always has to reflect the trna
availability of the given expression
host cell but yes of course and
especially in mammalian cells Xin
expression or protein expression is a
much more complex process and it is
actually influenced by many different
factors so once again if you take a look
at this align sequence here on this
slide which would represent a wild-type
sequence of your of your gene this
sequence might not be optimal for gene
expression so what you could do now is
you simply could replace each and every
codon with the most preferred codon for
your expression cell but this might also
not lead to success it's a simple a
simple codon back translation might
introduce some additional unwanted
motives such as repetitions or RNA
second
restructure which could be of course
huge obstacles for example for the
ribosomal machinery and therefore hambar
gene expression and so the goal always
is you need to find the trade-off
between codon optimisation and those
additional additional motives which
might influence protein expression and
this is why our IT software engineers
here at chena
basically they developed an optimization
algorithm which is not a simple code on
optimization but actually is an RNA
optimization and I will talk about this
in a little bit more detail in just
about one or two slides ok so yeah so
how do you solve now such a multi
parameter optimization problem because
you can imagine this is a huge
mathematical problem so what you can try
is you could do optimization in an
iterative way we're basically round
after round of optimization you deal
with different parameters such as in the
first round of optimization you deal
with codon usage in the second round you
take a look at RNA secondary structure
and so on and so on which you can
imagine is a quite time-consuming and
tedious process and in the end you might
not even end up with the very best
solution for your team you could try to
test all possible sequence combination
but yeah just imagine achene coding for
100 amino acid protein this would
already create such a huge sequence base
with billions and billions of different
sequence combinations that actually
there's no computer on earth who can
handle this in a timely manner you could
try a more random approach so called
Monte Carlo approach but yeah random
optimization certainly implies that you
will miss certain sequence combinations
and you might not end up with the best
solution and this is why our IT
engineers again our software developers
created a so-called sliding window
approach and what this approach does it
actually does test all possible sequence
combini
however it does this in only a limited
window of approximately 10 to 20 amino
acids within this window the very best
solution is created and the very first
codon is locked down and after locking
down this very first coat on the window
slides along your sequence from the 5
prime to the 3 prime end and the whole
optimization process within the window
is repeated all over and by doing this
step after step you constantly grow your
optimized sequence and of course there's
also application taking a look at an
extended window so that you can ensure
that you did not introduce additional
unwanted motives which in the end might
hamper protein expression again ok so if
you talk about protein production and we
want to talk today about the production
of human recombinant protein since
certainly this human proteins production
of human proteins is an indispensable
process for modern biotechnology in
biomedicine and by far mammalian in the
coli hosts are the most probably
prominent expression systems to do this
job the the advantages for he coli
expression are obvious it's fast growing
it's easy to handle and it's a quite
cheap and well understood organism but
of course especially for the production
of human recombinant protein it has
significant limitations such as the lack
of post translational modifications you
will never have a suitable membrane
environment for membrane proteins over
expression of your proteins might lead
to miss folding and aggregation so you
have to wrestle ooh belies your proteins
for example from inclusion bodies again
quite tedious and unwanted process and
especially if it comes to large size and
oligomeric proteins such as for example
antibodies you have significant
restrictions and again talking about
antibodies you will never be able to
produce an authentic human glycoproteins
so apparently producing a native protein
outside its native context is quite
difficult to achieve and in the end it
presumably will differ from its native
form and this is why to date more than
70% of recombinant protein
pharmaceuticals and proteins which are
used for vaccinations human therapy or
Diagnostics are currently produced in
mammalian cells since of course it
recommends all these cons of E coli
expression leaving us with the question
why do we then still need optimization
if we produce our protein in an
autologous tone and the answer to this
question is quite simple since in nature
expression is rarely optimized for
maximum expression for maximum years but
rather for maximum regulation and
according to this you still face
significant obstacles in mammalian
protein production such as
transcriptional silencing destabilized
or an unstable mRNA alternative splicing
events premature polyadenylation
elements caused simply in an inefficient
translational process so apparently all
problems of gene expression they find
they're thought in the trans gene itself
and this is why we believe that gene
optimization should provide and will
provide the technical solution to
overcome those problems and to
demonstrate this what we did is we
carried out a large-scale comparative
expression study where we basically
chose 50 standard human genes from the
ncbi data bank which are representing
the most interesting protein class
classes for for basic research such as
kinases transcription factors ribosomal
protein cytokines and membrane proteins
and what we did is we did novo
synthesize those genes as you can see on
the right side of this slide as Y type
genes as well as optimized genes
of course still both encoding for the
same amino acid sequence when I talk
about optimization I already mentioned
that our optimization approach is not a
simple codon usage optimization which we
talked about before but Radha is an RNA
optimization so we do in addition to
codon usage we also deal with GC content
in order to increase genetic stability
and this also promotes actually nuclear
export of your mRNA to the cytoplasm it
will remove any cryptic splice sites we
remove any premature protease sites in
order to avoid and premature
polyadenylation a termination process we
deal with direct repeats again
increasing genetic stability remove RNA
secondary structures which I said it
before can be huge obstacles for the
ribosomal machinery hampering
translation and we deal with so-called
killer sequences which are often a you
reach elements again in order to
increase genetic stability and to
prolong mRNA half-lives and yeah what we
did then is we basically transfected in
triplicates those wild-type and
optimized genes and compared into heck
to 9 3 cells and compare their
expression levels by a Western blot
analysis and as you can see here on this
slide and throughout the study the
results was quite stunning since yeah
actually the optimized constructs
outperformed their white type
counterparts in almost each and every
case and no matter which protein class
or else and the the results are
summarized on this slide so what came
out of this comparative expression study
was first of all that a hundred percent
of our gene optimized constructs did
Express which is proof for the high
reliability and reproducibility of
protein expression in vivo using
optimized genes and this is quite worth
mentioning since for example twelve
percent
the wild-type genes did not express at
all we saw that 92 6 96 percent of the
optimized gene showed at least equal or
higher protein expression levels when
actually 86% indeed showed higher
protein expression levels than their
white counterparts those expression
levels in this study were increased up
to 25 fold and we only had two low
performers where actually the Hawaiian
type gene performed better than the
optimized genes both were membrane
proteins and I would like to comment on
this on in just about a second on the
next slide
yeah what is shown here is that actually
those gene optimization effects that we
observed in the heck to nitrous system
we're not restricted to the 293 system
but since the results were reproducible
also in show as well as in sf9 infect
cells so simply by transfecting the very
same wild-type and optimized transgenes
into Joseph's and insect cells again the
optimized constructs outperform their
white counterparts however on this slide
I also want to draw your attention to
this vitamin K reductase complex which
is indicated by this red red circle red
dotted circle since actually this
vitamin K reductase complex was one out
of the two membrane proteins which in
the tool and three system showed a
higher expression performance using the
white egg gene however as you can see on
the on the far right when expressed in a
Cho system this effect was reversed
again now having the optimized concert
showing better expression performance
and yeah it is speculation but we do
speculate that what we observed in the 2
9 3 system was rather a toxic effect due
to over expression using the optimized
if using the optimized construct
rather than
actually the white light construct
showed a better performance with regard
to protein expression okay so next of
course we wanted to understand and
analyze which molecular mechanisms were
actually affected by our optimization
approach and in order to study this we
generated two stable cell lines using
same efficient flip in technology a cell
line expressing a wild-type version and
the second cell line expressing an
optimized version of a cytokine midpoint
alpha and we did those tests by using
stable cell lines since we really wanted
to compare a single copy effect of a
trans gene in the same genomic context
rather than comparing multi copy effects
which could lead to a saturation effects
when we use a transient system and again
first of all we compared expression
levels of those single trans jeans and
this was measured by a commercially
available
iliza test and as you can see the
optimized construct for the cytokine
showed an almost 300% increase or a
three-fold better protein expression
performance than the optimized gene and
then we wanted to understand what what
mechanisms are accounting for this and
in order to do this and I will not go
into the experimental details here but
what we measured is for example by using
a nuclear run on sa de novo synthesis
rates and what came out of this nuclear
run on experiments was that de novo
transcription rates were increased by
30% using an optimized construct we also
measured mRNA half-lives by doing
real-time PCR analysis and could could
demonstrate that mRNA stability
increased by 14% using the optimized
concern we also measured using northern
blot and real-time PCR mRNA steady state
level
and demonstrated that actually those
mRNA steady-state levels of cytokine
ripple and alpha mRNAs were increased by
80 percent and finally carrying out a
cell based translation si we also
demonstrated that even translation the
translational process was 20 percent
more productive when we used an
optimized construct so combining those
all those individual aspects finally
leads to this three-fold protein
expression increase using an optimized
construct and those experiments clearly
demonstrate that indeed our optimization
approached targets each individual step
of protein synthesis from transcription
to translation which is yeah quite quite
nice results okay um yeah we also could
show that by using optimized genes and
over expression over expression of
protein using optimized genes did not
affect solubility or functionality which
is of course a quite common observation
we talked about this before when you
have an e coli host so over expression
over expression of your gene in an
e.coli OS might lead to miss folding or
aggregation of your target and ending up
in inclusion bodies again quite tedious
process to Risa Lou belies your protein
and make use of it so what we did here
is we tested a set of kindnesses again
express those kindnesses from wild-type
genes and optimized genes then purified
those kindnesses using hammock affinity
chromatography and then we carried out a
pulldown of those kindnesses using
substrate coded beads and then we could
compare equal amounts of kindnesses that
were obtained from wild type and the
optimized construct in in the kinase si
and we could demonstrate that
functionality was completely the same
there was not negative effect on
activity due to over expression of those
proteins and yeah finally to finish up
this first part of my talk I also would
like to draw your attention to another
quite nice feature for optimized genes
since those represent really valuable
tools for functional genomics so yeah
you all know that of course is AI RNA
mediated knockdown is a quite widespread
method to analyze cellular function but
the true challenge of those experiments
always is to differentiate between a
true cellular phenotype and so-called
off-target effect since the given si RNA
might also trigger a multitude of
secondary mechanisms in the cell which
could lead to a certain cell phenotype
so when you do those experiments you
always have to carry out a rescuing
experiment where you basically restore
the wild-type phenotype and you do those
rescue experiments by Co transfecting
your s i RNA targeting the endogenous
gene together with an exertion this
version of your of your gene in order to
restore the wild-type phenotype but
those experiments were often difficult
to carry out because of due to the
unavailability of a offer of Si RNA
which target the endogenous gene but not
the exception as gene you want to use
for the rescue and now with optimized
genes basically carrying silent
mutations you have the free choice to
design your si RNA and to design those
si or functional genomics experiments
and such an experiment is displayed here
on this slide so we analyzed CDC 2 which
is actually the catalytic subunit
of the M phase promoting factor enabling
cells to enter mitosis so what we did is
first of all again we compare expression
levels using a wild-type and an
optimized version of this construct and
we obtained an almost three-fold
increase
using the optimized Sheen then we
carried out a fox analysis and what this
what is shown here is basically on the
upper left is the Y type state where we
could demonstrate that in in Y type
stand approximately 16% of cells are in
g2 phase yeah ready to end on mitosis on
the upper right then we performed in as
high RNA mediated knockdown of cdc2 and
what we did is we induced by doing this
we induced a cell cycle arrest having no
more than 36% of cells in g2 phase which
could no longer end up mitosis then we
performed the rescue experiment on the
lower left where we Co transfected an
optimized version of CDC - together with
the SI RNA and as you can see the amount
of cells which were arrested in g2 phase
dropped down to almost wild-type levels
indicating that we reversed the cellular
phenotype and that indeed cdc2 was the
target of the SI RNA mediate knockdown
okay so by this I would like to finish
on this first part of my talk this is
all published data if you want to take a
look in more detail into the
experimental procedures this is a free
access journal it's published in PLoS
ONE and just to sum up this first part
we really could state that gene design
and commercial gene synthesis increases
overall expression success rate it
improves protein years in general and as
far as we can tell it has no negative
effect on protein solubility or activity
of the encoded protein and again if
you're interested in cellular in paraná
rni experiments those are also valuable
to us for functional genomics okay
moving on this is actually now
unpublished data and just to sum this up
of course we also wanted to
benchmark our optimization approach to
other algorithms which are out in fierce
and what we did here is we basically
again we chose a set of kindnesses
optimize those kindnesses and compared
the expression level using our optimized
genes to wild-type levels but also two
targets which were optimized by our
competitors and what came out of this
study was that indeed our gene optimal
size optimizer software was the only
technology which showed consistently
higher expression levels compared to
wild-type expression levels again
demonstrating the high reliability of
this optimization process on protein
expression in vivo and it was actually
the only technology which did not fail
which did not fail at least for one or
the other gene while our competitors
algorithms actually did fail at least
for one or the other gene so we believe
if we really have a quite good tool here
in hands and now we could also make
benefit using this optimization approach
and combine it with those highly
advanced expression systems which are
offered through thermo Fisher and with
this I would like to go over to the
second part of my talk and introduce you
to those highly advanced expression
systems and how we can help you with
your research by offering this complete
workflow from gene to protein again I
showed this slide more or less right in
the beginning but just to mention it
again here at chena Thermo Fisher
Scientific we do offer a quite
comprehensive product and service
portfolio from project design to the
final expressed purified and analyzed
protein and I want to mention this
because this is quite crucial for many
of our customers everything is coming
from one hand and everything is produced
in now starting from only go synthesis
force in gene synthesis to final
and purification of your protein of
course we carry out our work to the
highest quality standards and as I will
show you we also have a very easy to
order process with our service gene to
protein service of a th in China we are
offering mammalian protein expression
and purification using those highly
advanced expression system namely the
free side and the XP 293 as well as the
freestylin XP geo systems and we also do
sf9 as of 21 and hi-5 insect cell
protein production using the back to
back system we strongly focus on
mammalian protein expression because
yeah we talked about this before this
indeed delivers the highest quality
proteins with the most proper functions
and as most of our customers are reallyy
biopharma and biotech customers who are
interested in antibody production those
only are the expression systems we have
to go for I don't want to go into too
much detail here but basically what we
offer is we do offer different service
types where you can order your protein
for example simply from a specified
culture volume or you can request a
specified protein amount but this always
will involve a pilot service before
basically where we start out with a 1
liter culture for example in order to
determine title or yield of purified
protein in order to deliver the
specified protein amount that you as the
customer are requesting and with this I
basically would like to share some
success stories that we could offer to
our customers by combining those highly
advanced expression system and those
optic on those optimized genes that we
are using so this first example was
actually work that was carried out
at a large farmer customer so he did the
protein part of the work in-house
because he wanted to use his own
expression system but he came to us and
he had very poor expression performance
for a set of four different antibodies
that he produced in-house basically yeah
with non existing performance so what we
then did is we optimized his heavy and
light chain genes for expression in
chosen and what when we send those
constructs back to the customer and he
performed protein expression in-house he
actually experienced
22-250 sevenfold increase in protein
production levels and if you consider
making an almost non Express that you
were quite decent explainer and more
than 650 fold increase in protein
expression another example and this is
actually now customer examples which was
done here in-house Aegina using our gene
to protein service and customer used
heck to name three systems so if we
start with the examples the table on the
lower left customer came to us and he
requested the production of two
different antibodies where when he
produced them in-house he got poor
titles of only approximately two mixed
per leader however the customer was
using white type heavy and light chain
genes he was using an endogenous leader
peptide although he was already using
our quite good freestyle 293 system and
the corresponding expression construct
what we did then here is when we
produced it here at chena we optimized
those heavy and light chain genes we
replaced his secretion leader by
replacing the endogenous leader peptide
with an IG Kappa leader peptide switched
the expression construct and transected
they are highly advanced xp2 9-3 system
and as you can see those expression
titers were increased more than a
hundredfold so this customer was quite
happy after obtaining
those title results comparable story on
the upper on the upper left again
customer came to us he wanted to express
instead of six different antibodies and
she provided our three C's in-house
production levels which are reflected by
the white pass
so however he was using again Y type
heavy in light chain genes and he was
using his in-house production system
what we did here at ginarte is we
optimized the heavy and light chain
genes we tested the constructs still in
the customer provided expression plasmid
but switched to the Freestyle tune and
three system and this is represented by
the dark blue bar and as you can see for
most of the antibody targets we already
observed a quite good expression level
increase we then also tested the very
same setting but switching into the
expression plasmid which is actually the
plasmid recommended for the free society
to learn three system and again this
gave an expression brewers for at least
some of the of the targets that we were
testing and then finally when we tested
those optimized targets in the highly
advanced XP two nine three system you
can see that yeah a significant level
increase in protein production was
achieved again yeah
demonstrating that we here could
increase protein production levels
almost 50 fold for those for certain
antibody targets so yeah again this
hopefully demonstrates you how your
research can benefit by the combination
of our ccino ccino optimizer technology
with those advanced expression system
namely the Freestyle tune and three or
the Kymco XP to 93 systems which are
offered through Thermo Fisher Scientific
and I also want to mention that those
systems of course they are commercially
available so which guarantees you the
full transfer ability of those processes
for further in house work if you want to
do the
experiments at a later time point in
your own lab and of course if you order
a protein with us you will always get
the expression construct in the
respective expression plasmid as well
and finally yeah I also want to draw
your attention to our newest launch of
service since we are also now offering
protein service using the highly
advanced Expedia system and I am sure
you will hear a lot more about the
system during this web conference since
this is really a very exciting and very
well system for doing protein production
so customer success story that is
displayed here on the slide customer had
again a panel of antibodies which he
almost could not produce in-house or
very poor performers when he produced
them in-house and he wanted to he wanted
us to deliver him a decent amount of
protein so first of all we tested those
targets in the XP 293 system and as you
can see at least four out of those six
antibody targets showed quite ease and
expression levels in the XP 293 system
of approximately hundred to two hundred
mix per liter Titans however we still
had two targets which actually showed
almost no expression at all in the XP
293 system so when we then tested those
six antibody targets in the XP chill
system you can see that expression
levels significantly rose further and
making basically out of those two
non-expressive
quite even the Express which tied us
from 100 mix to 200 mix per liter so
customer of course was quite happy with
that and also the quality of those
purified antibodies was very good as I
want to indicate you here on the right
side of this slide since even after
affinity chromatography
yeah monomial level of those expressed
antibodies were almost above 95% so
meaning that no additional polishing
steps was requested or required in order
to deliver high quality and javadi
protein and yeah of course those systems
are not restricted to antibody
productions since they work as well for
for example subs or other secreted
epitope tag non antibody targets okay um
on this slide very briefly I just want
to give you a snapshot if you order a
protein expression service a protein
production service at chena how an
documentation could look like but i also
want to strongly mention that we are
really a highly customized service where
you have the free choice of expression
system expression plasmid culture volume
analytical or purification steps which
are requested according to your needs so
this would be just a look at a basic a
standard documentation but of course
this can be pimped according to your
needs
okay yeah how can you order a protein
production protein purification at chena
please go to the SEM official website
and search there for chena gene
synthesis if you did that please click
on chin and cell lines and proteins and
this will direct you to the actual
website where you can order our service
here you can download a very brief
questionnaire where you simply can
provide to us your amino acid sequence
your protein sequence where you can
choose the expression system you want to
go for where you can choose on the
epitope tag you want us to use for
purification and some additional things
that might be requested by you as the
customer you send them to us
- n - a mailbox and then usually within
two to three business days you receive a
quote from your respective sales manager
and yeah this brings me close to the end
of my talk just to sum up again I
strongly want to point out that our gene
to protein process is completely done
in-house providing full control for you
as the customer as well as for us as the
manufacturer so there's no need of data
transfer no need of material transfer
which is very crucial for many of our
farmer and biotech customers you have
the full design flexibility starting
with the project design where you can
choose purification strategy where you
can choose the expression system if
you're interested in a certain click
oscillation pattern for example of your
antibody and of course upstream of our
protein service unit we already have
highly specialized manufacturing
departments for example who deliver high
quality plasma preparations to us which
we can use for transfecting your targets
yeah we are quite flexible in expression
scales and we are very experienced with
paralyzed workflows for high throughput
of your projects or if you have multiple
targets that you want to have produced
we are very experienced doing that and
of course as I hopefully could
demonstrate you we really use the
best-in-class reagents by using thermo
Fisher XP 2 + 3 + XP Cho systems as well
as the Freestyle - nutrient show systems
with regard to purification we use
state-of-the-art equipment and we have
constantly growing capacities of
approximately 2,000 antibody
purifications per year plus additional
500 non NC purifications crania and
those capacities are constantly growing
and
depending on your need we can make
things happen quite quite quickly since
we are part of such a huge organization
which is thermo Fisher Scientific and of
course depending on the need of your
project we also can provide you with
state-of-the-art analytical data of the
produced protein and you are requesting
ranging from inter toxin measurements to
monomer detection of your antibody
capillary gel electrophoresis whatever
is requested again we are highly
customized and so we think this is a
very smart way for you as a customer to
receive a purified protein in a very
short delivery time and I mentioned it
before you always also will get the
optimized gene in the respective
expression vector for further in
housework and yeah I also want to point
out that during each step of your
project you will be supported by a
highly experienced and highly motivated
project management team which basically
will support you at every step during
your project and with that yeah I would
like to finish my my talk and basically
yeah would like to end over to the Q&A
part if you have questions for me thank
you so much dr. fat for that informative
presentation and such important data we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
this webinar audience members if you
have questions you'd like to anse ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our first set of
questions
dr. fat an audience member would like to
know how long does it take to receive a
protein
what is your turnaround time
okay so turnaround time of course
somehow the complexity of your project
plays a role here and also the batch
size of your project my player role here
but I would say I can say for a standard
protein to protein project starting from
project design to chain synthesis sub
cloning plasmid preparation and then
protein production using our service the
standard turnaround time would be 30
business days wonderful thank you
and which purification methods do you
offer including aperture tags again I
said it before so we are really a highly
customized and we are also happy to
adopt customer protocols if they are
provided but standard projects basically
involve a first as the first of an
affinity chromatography step and with
regard to epitope text you have the full
choice of epitope tags which are out in
the field but standard epitope tags we
are using of course his tags we use flex
reification threat tags we can do the
world steps basically putting and and
that's the beauty because we have gene
synthesis upfront and a project design
up front so you can put n-terminus istic
for example and c-terminal strep tag and
then to a two-way purification of course
we offer additional polishing steps so
we can do ion exchange chromatography
afterwards and yeah especially when it
comes to antibodies and I said it before
most of our customers are antibody
customers we always include a polishing
step using size-exclusion chromatography
and here we have all scales of columns
to offer
you made some wonderful questions coming
in here's another
how much protein will I get if I order
your service well this is a question we
get a lot which I obviously cannot
answer per se because the yield of your
protein always depends on the target
productivity and it also depends on the
requested quality that you that you that
you have as a customer I only pre flea
touched this during my talk but if you
if you if you request a specified
protein amount we always usually do a
1-liter pilot-scale
and based on this we can determine titer
we can determine we can purify it and
determine the years of the purified
protein and based on this you can choose
if you need additional protein and want
to scale up your project or if this is
already sufficient for you answer that
perfect and doctor what is the cost
example like 100 milligrams or one gram
of protein what would that cost question
goes in the same direction of course
again this depends on the target
productivity and it also depends on the
quality of your final protein that you
request again we would in case of such a
project if you request for example 100
milligrams we would start out with the 1
liter pilot and in many many if not most
cases if you want to produce 100
milligrams of an antibody the xp2 9-3
system for example already delivers this
amount of protein so you're good to go
with the one liter pilot this pilot if
you ask me for cost this usually starts
around 4 to 5 K I assume but yeah this
would have to request
with your respective sales
representatives but that's the range I
would say and then usually you already
get the 100 mix out of this pilot if you
need one crab of course difficult to say
but based on the pilot results we can
then estimate how much more culture we
have to produce and then we will have to
set up a follow-up project in order to
deliver this one gram of protein thank
you in line with that
what are your capacities yeah capacities
so I really can say we are very well
equipped here for our protein service
but capacities of course depend sort of
the product mix which is which is in the
pipeline at a given moment but I could
say that if we are talking small-scale
expressions in the range of 100
milliliters so we could do approximately
300 antibody expressions purifications
per week in the lower scale 100
milliliter scale if we talk mid size
scale in the one Rita 1 liter range I
would say we have capacities to produce
60 and the bodies per week and then yeah
I say we can offer up to 50 little AIF
production of course this then capacity
capacities are getting a little bit
lower for those large scale projects but
in the 50 liter range we can do 3 to 4
antibody projects per month I would say
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions how do you guarantee that
someone gets something for the money if
they submit this with you
so usually how we do set up our project
is that we set them up have sort of
milestone projects so for example if you
have a completely unknown protein which
has never been produced before so we
would start with approach with a
small-scale expression which we call an
expression proof basically to determine
is your protein expression thing how is
it expressing in order to determine best
harvest day if the protein secreted is a
seller layer where we have to purify it
from and if and you will always I said
this during my talk you will during each
step of your project you will be in line
with your project manager and he will
give you real-time updates on your
project and so you if you're not
satisfied how a project is going you
could stop at a given milestone actually
we don't face this a lot so but I guess
the guarantee that you get something for
your money is based on the fact that we
always do pilot expressions as sort of a
milestone project which ensures that you
don't have to pay the whole money for a
complete project if we cannot produce it
for example but this rarely happens I
really have to say right an audience
member would like to know what is part
of your QC or what is included in the
documentation yeah I was all touched
that very briefly during my presentation
again it's highly customized so I would
say if you the the minimal documentation
you always will receive would be an SDS
page of your purified protein a Western
blot if if needed a protein
concentration the delivered amount
and if we talk antibody for example and
HPLC analysis stating the monomer
content of your antibody practices based
on your on your needs this can be
extended significantly so we certainly
can do and the toxin measurement we can
do capillary gel electrophoresis in
order to determine purity of your
protein so you have to free choice here
so and this is always set up with you at
the customer when we design the project
thank you and do you offer membrane
protein purification in this process
here you got me so although we highly
customized we do not offer membrane
purification however we do offer
membrane expression we do not offer
membrane purification because this is
basically always a real research project
and we are fee-for-service based type of
service but what we always can do is we
can shape we can transect cells with the
trans with your membrane transgene
express those membrane proteins and ship
cell phase to you and the documentation
then basically would include a proof of
expression such as investment blood and
but purifying membrane proteins how no
we are not offering unfortunately thank
you so much thank you again for this
wonderful presentation do you have any
closing remarks before we close for this
webinar we don't have time for to me
other questions unfortunately well if
your some remarks yeah I hope I could
demonstrate you how we can help you with
your research by combining those our our
classical
synthetic genes with those highly
advanced expression systems and yeah if
you have additional questions I'm happy
you can reach out to me via email or
else and I will be happy to answer any
additional questions if I can and yeah
just go to the website and again we have
a highly dedicated project management
team so if you are in good hands when
you're ordering a project with us so you
really get real real-time updates we can
provide you with intermediate reports
during the project if you want to decide
how we should go on with your project
because of course you are the expert and
we sometimes cannot decide if your
interest is quantity or quality of
proteins or we can if you want to we can
let you make decisions how to continue
in real time during your project and
yeah again you can reach out to me at
any time and hope I can I hope I could
demonstrate you some nice data with this
talk dr. Paz thank you so much for your
presentation today I'd also like to
thank lab roots and get Co part of
thermo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcast possible
audience members additional questions
will be answered and published on Thermo
Fisher Scientific website you will
receive an email notification when
answers are available before we go I
want to let everyone know the today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share this
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
enjoy the rest of your conference
goodbye